What is up by here from my senses calm and
welcome to another Unreal Engine mini course
here on YouTube. I mean, where else could it
be? You're on YouTube, this is YouTube. Anyways,
before we begin, you always know that I first
show you the game that you're going to create.
But before we do that, help the algorithm promote
my channel so that we can grow together, hit that
like button, make sure that you comment, share the
video so that others can see and subscribe that
way you're helping me This is the only thing I'm
asking you. Okay, so now let's get inside and see
the game that we're going to create the if I hit
the play button, we have the nice snake over here,
it's the snake's head. Now one thing that we see
over here is that the controls of the snake are
pretty hard. As you can see, I still cannot
get the first food. And the reason for that
is because we have one variable inside of our game
that is going to allow us to control the snake,
you see that I just die. If I press the restart
button, we restart and that variable is a delay
number. And the smaller that number is, the
faster the snake will be. And it will be
easier for us to control it. As you can see,
the more we eat, the larger the snake gets,
and the faster the snake will get. And that means
we will be able to control it much faster. As you
can see, the larger the snake gets. I have
more control over it because well we need to
have more control over the snake when this knee
gets larger. If you're wondering, what's that
circle circle in the middle, that dot i have no
idea. It's probably some kind of glitch. It's
not part of our game. But it doesn't bother us
anyways, as you can see, now the snake is much
faster and I can control it much better. But
I still died. We can go back here in the game.
And we can set this delay from point two to
point one. So the smaller the delay number is,
the faster the snake will be pay attention.
Now the snake is crazy fast as you can see,
look at the speed of that snake. Look at the crazy
speed of that snake pay attention. We also have
the score at the top. And yeah, I can control the
snake now very, very well. Very Val Val. Well that
is. So yeah, we have 1000 for the score. I am
pretty good at this game. I'm the best nobody
can beat me and yada yada yada. You saw someone
we die the snake please. Short that animation,
like everything disappears, goes transparent,
so on and so forth. I'm going to die over here.
And you saw that what I just mentioned. Anyways,
this is the game that we are going to create. And
we are going to learn a lot inside of this game.
Even though it looks small, it looks a small game,
we're going to still learn a lot, a lot of
cool techniques, a lot of things that we're
going to implement, especially in 2d because
Unreal Engine is mostly for 3d and people
don't know and they're not basically no to
the tutorials for Unreal Engine out there.
Except for some official ones anyways, I don't
want to bla bla bla bla bla bla bla, just make
sure that you comment, like the video, share it
and subscribe to the channel and enjoy the course
what else can I say, see in the next video, or in
the next part of this video. Take care. So let's
get started. And as always, you know that we first
create or open the Unreal Engine Project Browser,
click here on games and click on Next. Over here
we can have a blank project that is not a problem,
click on Next again, blueprint, we can leave that
because you're going to use primarily bla bla
blueprints in this project, no Starter Content
over here, you are going to select where you are
going to store your project and over here you are
going to name it. So here I'm going to say well,
we cannot begin it with a 2d. So we can say snake
2d. And then I'm going to click on Create Project.
And of course, as always, we need to wait until
Unreal Engine takes mercy upon us and you know,
opens the project and so on and so forth. So what
I'm going to do is I am going to cut out the video
right now. And I'm going to come back when the
project opens project. Yeah, so see in a few.
And here we are, I was surprised it opened pretty
quickly. Anyways, that is not important. What's
important is that we click over here where it says
show or hide the source panel. And then over here
we have the content. Of course everything is
empty, we don't have anything. But we do have
these assets that you can download by clicking the
link below this video. So simply download assets
and you also have a complete project there as
well. So this is what you need to copy but before
that over here in the content, you're going to
right click and click here show in Explorer.
And over here it is going to open in the Explorer
which is well a folder and it is going to open
where your content is for this project. Let
me just go back over here for the assets now
copy everything you see over here. So copy this
so simply you're going to right click and copy
and go back over here and paste it when you paste
it you will see it in your project and there you
go. So we have over here the sprites that we are
going to use. We also have here are flipbooks
don't worry about that you can just click them
now and Open them over here. We will see later
on what they are, how to use them, so on and so
forth. But what's important is that everything is
working and we have everything set up. Now what we
are going to do first things first, I'm going to
right click here and create a new folder, and I'm
going to call it maps. And I'm going to Ctrl S to
save this current map. And in the maps over here,
we're simply going to add a no name ID gameplay,
because you're only going to have one map,
everything is going to happen over there.
So you can save it as a gameplay map over here.
Now before we do anything with it, so we are not
going to touch anything right now later on, we
will do, the first thing that I'm going to do
is go over here and again, right click and create
a new folder. And I'm going to call this bad boy
blue prints. Inside of the blueprints for folder,
we are going to right click, and we are going
to create a user interface. And it's going to
be a Widget Blueprint. And I know this is not
what we usually do. But you know, we are going
to do it this time. So BP underscore u i HUD,
this is how you can call it you can call hire
however you want to call it you can call it Carl
Kenny, you know, I don't know, whatever. But I'm
going to call it BP UI HUD. What's going to happen
here inside of our BB UI HUD. First things first
in our canvas panel over here, I'm going to go on
the palette here at the top, and we are going to
search for a horizontal box. And I'm going to add
the Horizontal Box over here inside of our panel.
And here you go. This is our Horizontal Box.
What I'm also going to do with the Horizontal
Box is that I'm going to call it score box.
Next, I'm going to click on it and I am going
to click here on the anchors and set the anchor
at the top center. So over here, and we are going
to reposition it as well. So what we are going to
do for the position x is going to be negative 150.
Position y is going to be 32. The size x is going
to be 400. And the size of y is going to be 64.
There you go. So position x minus 150. Position y
32 size x 400. Size y 64. As the title suggests
that this is a score panel. So what we are going
to do with the score panel is that we are going
to add a text to it. So over here in the palette
in the search, we are going to filter for text
and we don't want the rich text block but the
usual normal text block and put it over here. Now
this text block I am going to call it score title.
And what we are going to do with this one is that
over here, padding, we are not going to touch that
alto everything can be as is over here over here
for the text block, we are not going to leave it
like that. Instead, we're going to say score,
column and space. Also over here for the font,
we are going to set it at 44 so that it is a
little bit larger, as you can see over here.
And also for the color, I'm going to click in
over here where it says hex linear paste 741 c 00
ff and when you click OK, it's going to well
be this color. Now of course you can pause
the video and see this number over here. So 741 c
00 ff, but it's not important, you don't have to
do it the same way I did. It's not mandatory,
you know, because I know that a lot of people
follow this. And they think like they need to have
everything as I do. It's not mandatory for you to
do that. But if you want you can pause the video
and again I you know dictated two times the hex
color for it. Anyways moving forward. Next we are
going to again, take a text and put it over here.
And this text over here is going to be our score
value. For the score value. We are going to set
the font size to 44. Same as what we did for the
score. Over here where it says text block or the
text that's inside we're simply going to say zero.
And again for the hex linear color paste 741 c 00
ff and click OK. So now this is what we have, as
you can see here, score there you go at the top,
there you go. So we can compile and save
this. Now of course we are still not done.
Over here in the palette. What we can do or what
we need to do, we are going to filter for a canvas
panel, click on it and drag it over here not as
a child of the score box, but as a child of the
canvas panel because this canvas panel over here
is going to be our game over panel and that panel.
So the game over panel, what we are going
to do with it is we're going to click on it,
and over here, it says anchors, I'm going
to click on the drop down list over here.
For the x, I'm going to leave it at zero for the Y
minimum is going to be point five. For the maximum
of x, I'm going to say one, and a maximum of the
Y minimum is going to be point five. And you can
see now where the anchor is, is basically
here in the middle, and it's stretched.
So this is our anchor, again, for the minimum
for the x over here, point, or actually for
x is zero. for y, it's point five, for the
maximum of the X is one, and maximum for the Y
is point five. Now over here, where it says offset
left, we are going to say 512. For the position y,
we're going to say 550. So 550, for the offset,
right, we are going to save 404 the size, why
we are going to set that at 598. There you go. So
this is going to be our canvas. And purposefully,
it is here at the bottom, because later on, we're
going to animate it and move it up. But before we
do that, what we are going to do is the following,
we are going to, again, go here in the canvas, or
actually in the palette and search for a text and
apply or drag and drop that text under the game
over panel. Now this text is going to be our game
over text and we are going to hit enter Of course,
you can Compile and Save this so that we can save
all of these changes. Next, what we are going
to do for our game over text is that I am going
to select it. And for the anchors, I'm going to
leave it at the top left corner. So we're not
going to touch anything here for the minimum,
the maximum, we are not going to touch anything,
the size x is going to be at 100. And the size y
is going to be at 30. But over here in the
font, we are going to leave it at Roboto bold,
the size for the font is going to be 90. And where
it says text block, we are simply going to say
game over like this. And over
here for the color and capacity.
For the hex linear, I'm going to paste FF and then
we have 1234 zeros. So ff 0000. And again, FF at
the end, which is going to be our red color. What
you can do as well over here for our game over
for the text, I'm going to select it and over here
we can, you know, like add a few spaces over here
or a tab, and it looks like this. And you can add
it all caps. So you can have it all caps as well.
So again, this is not mandatory, you will not like
ruin the game, if you don't put the red color. And
instead you put the blue color or whatever. So I'm
just saying that putting that out there anyways,
Compile and Save. Last but not least save the
text again. And over here in the game over panel,
add that text and this one is going to be a
re start text for the restart text over here
inside of the anchors, we are going to set the
minimum for the y to be one maximum for x going to
be zero and maximum for the Y is going to be one
again over here minimum for the x is zero, minimum
for the Y is one maximum for the X is one and
a maximum for the Y it is one over here for the
offset on the left side, we're going to leave it
at zero position y is going to be negative at the
offset the right is going to be zero and the size
y is going to be 64. I am also going to set over
here I'm going to leave it the font at Roboto bold
but the font size is going to be at 50. And over
here for our hex linear color, I'm going to paste
ff c 600 f f. So again, it's f f c 600 f f and I'm
going to hit OK. Where it says the text block
we are simply going to say press and over here
in quotes are actually in single quotes are with
capital. And again single quote and to start a new
game. There you go. simply going to this
play this over here. As you can see press R
to start a new game and Compile and Save that
as you can see, this is with single quotes so
you don't have to do it. I mean you can again
but it's not mandatory, it will not destroy
our game and it will not make it you know like
better or what ever Moving forward, let us now
animate our game over panel. And in order to do
that, we need to select it and over here we are
going to click on the animation. And I clicked
over here on the green button in case you didn't
notice over here in that animation step, and now
I'm going to select animation and first rename it.
So this is going to be game over animation. And
now we need to select this game over animation.
And over here in the timeline where it says
track, we're going to click on over here,
and we want the game over panel Canvas panel slot,
this is what we need. And when you click on that,
there you go. So we have the canvas panels,
slot one. Now when we click on this bad boy,
now over here, when you hover over on the plus
button, which is the dark plus button at the right
side, you're going to click on this track. And
from here, we're going to select the layout data
offsets, and there you go. When you click on the
plus button over here, we have the left, top right
bottom, so on and so forth. And automatically,
as you can see over here, we have the keyframes
for all all four of these. Now this over here
is the timeline or however you want to call it
a basically, that's, you know, like the the track
that you can move and this is the track over here,
what I'm going to do is I'm going to move with you
over here on one, which is one second. And for the
top over here, we are going to click on the plus
button to add a track over here. And for the top,
we are going to move it from 550. So 550,
we are going to move it over to negative
64. So over here, we are going to add and let me
just type in minus 64, which is as you can see,
it is going to move the panel at the top now again
over here only for the top, we're not going to
touch the left, the right the bottom, the so on
and so forth. So we are not going to touch any
of these Now make sure that you Compile and Save
this bad boy. So again, it is only for our top,
and it goes by clicking here on the animation
to create the animation, I'm going to remove it
when you create the animation. So click on the
plus button. When you create that animation over
here for the track, you are going to select
First things first, like this one over here.
And now select the game over panel Canvas panel
slot when you select that, and from there,
you're going to click on the plus button over
here. And you're going to select the layout
data or offsets. And of course for the top we are
going to move it so there you go. So now we have
the animation as you can see over here. So there
you go. This is animation, Compile and Save that.
Now before we proceed, we are also going to do a
little bit blueprinting, which is what I call the
blueprint programming. So over here, select the
restart text. And over here, when you select it
over here, in the details tab you have this is
variable. So we are going to click on that. So
click on each variable. And over here for the game
over do the same thing, click on each variable.
And for the score value as well click on his
variable, let me just Compile and Save that,
when you do this, you are enabling these variables
are these elements, the text elements, the UI
elements to actually be variables. So now we can
go here in the graph at the top right corner,
as you can see, so over here, when we click on the
graph, we're going to go over here. Now we don't
need the pre construct, we do need the construct
and we will use the tick as well. Or actually we
will create an invent for that. But over here in
the event construct, what we are going to do is
we are going to take the game over text, so we
need the game over text and we need the restart
text. There you go. And from here, we are
going to set visibility, so drag a note
from them and click on Set visibility. And I'm
going to plug in the execution order over here.
And I'm also going to plug in the restart text
over here as well which means both of these now
are the targets for this and we are going to set
the visibility to hidden which means they will
not be visible. So when we run the game, we are
not going to make the game over and the restart
text visible. Next over here below that I'm
going to right click and create a custom event.
And this custom event is going to be update score.
The update score is going to have a parameter so
click on it and over here for the inputs click
on the plus button and the parameter over here is
going to be score and instead of Boolean we are
going to make it an integer. So now from here,
we're going to take the score value. And I'm just
going to move a little bit down. Take the score
value and put it over here. From the score
value I'm going to say set text Like this, plug
in the execution order over here, and plug in the
score in the text, and of course, it is going to
automatically convert this integer to a text and
plug it in over here. And this is how we are going
to display the score to the user. So this event is
going to be used to display the score as I already
said. And last but not least, again, right click
and create a custom event. Now this custom event
is going to be our game over event like this.
And for our game over event, we are going to take
our text again. So we can select all of these and
we can Ctrl C to copy them, and then Ctrl V to
paste them. And I'm going to plug in the execution
over here. But this time, it's not going to be
hidden but visible. So the visibility is going to
be visible, which means we are going to be able
to see the game over text and the restart text.
And last but not least, we're going to take the
game over animation, the one that we have created
a moment ago over here. And from the game over
animation, we're going to drag and know that
we're going to say play animation like this blog
in the execution order over here. And everything
is going to be as easy as playback speed is going
to be one, the Play Mode is going to be forward
over here in animation Game Over animation start
at time zero number of loops to play is going to
be one and Compile and Save that. So this is what
we are going to use later on when we create our UI
widget, we are going to use it and we are going to
first get a reference to it. And then from there,
we are going to use these custom events to play
the animation when the snake dies, update the
score when we have the new score. And of course
hide the text. When we start the game. Moving
forward, we are going to go back here inside of
our gameplay. And I am going to select everything
inside of the level. So from atmospheric fog to
sphere reflection, capture, and simply delete
all of that, and yes to all delete everything,
and we have a dark level. Of course, this is
not what we want. So we are going to go here
inside of the sprites folder. So this is our
sprites folder. And I'm going to drag here,
the background sprite, so I'm going to put that
inside. And I'm also going to find the gray
back ground. And let me just find it here. Here
it is. So we have that gray background sprite,
and we have the back ground sprite, what we are
going to do is select the back ground sprite
for the location x over here inside of
the transform. So this bad boy over here,
the location x is going to be at zero. And
what did I do, I apparently deleted it. So
select the background sprite over here location
is going to be zero for the X for the Y is going
to be negative 20 for the Z it is going to be
zero rotation, we're not going to touch that.
But over here for the scale, we are going to set
it to be 555 on all three axes. So x, y, and z,
all three of these they are going to have that
scale. Now also, what I am going to do is here for
the sprite color, instead of white, we're going
to set over here the hex linear 2345 C, nine zero
FF. So again, it's 345 c nine zero FF and again,
you see it just changes a little bit the color.
And again, what I wanted to say is, you don't have
to have exact the exact same color as I do, but
if you want just pause the video, we're here, take
a look at this hex linear again, 345 c nine zero
f f. Now moving forward for our gray background
Sprite. So for the gray backgrounds, right,
we are going to set the x at minus 50.
This is for the position the position y
is minus 10. The position z is going to be
minus 50 rotation, we're not going to touch
that. And over here for the scale x is going
to be 12. Scale y is also going to be 12.
And last but not least the scale z it is going
to be 10 There you go. Now also for this bad boy,
we are going to click here on the sprite color
and where is that it's basically right over here
in the sprite. So when you click on this bright
color over here hex linear, I'm going to paste
this for two to a five nine c c. So 422
a five, nine cc or simply pause the video
and check out for yourself. I'm going to click ok
and this is what we have. So this is going to be
our game background. Now of course we're still not
finished because we do need to add one more thing
over here. So I'm going to go over here where it
says please actors in search for classes here. I'm
going to filter for the camera and I'm simply
going to drag and drop this camera over here.
Now for this camera, we of course need
to reposition it. So select the camera,
the exposition is going to be minus 50, the y
position is going to be 100. And the Z position is
going to be also minus 50. So it's minus 50. There
you go. And the rotation on the z axis is going
to be negative 90. And this is what our camera
sees. If we select the camera, you see over here,
when you select it, and you click on it over here
in the world outliner, this is what the camera
sees. But of course, one more thing that we need
to do is over here, the projection mode, I'm going
to change it from perspective to orthographic.
And automatically, you can see how the preview of
the camera over here changed. Now also over here,
or toe width, I'm going to save 4500. And again,
you see over here, how the camera view changed,
or what the camera sees, has changed. Now again,
I'm not going to like experiment with this, you
can see this on your own what is what this is
doing the order the width, and you can change from
orthographic to perspective to see the difference.
So that way you can instead of me explaining
what it does, it just changes the view of the
camera and the width, and so on and so forth. But
again, as I said projection mode, just change it
from orthographic to perspective, and vice versa.
And you will see that now we do have one thing
that is not working if I hit the
play button, this is what we see. And
this is not how we want to see our level we want
to see it, as we saw in the preview of our game.
How the camera is looking at the level
so that we can actually see it better.
And in order to do that. While we are over here
inside of the gameplay tab for the gameplay level,
we are going to click here on this blueprints
drop down list. So click on this drop down list.
And we're going to click on Open Level Blueprint.
And it is going to open this over here, we don't
need the tick event. But what I'm going to do
is I'm going to move this over here and go back.
So as you can see I have a floating window. So I
have a floating window of the gameplay level over
here on I'm simply going to do is take the camera
actor and place it over here. So from the world
outliner here it is simply get the camera, drag
it and drop it over here. And now we can well dock
the gameplay tab again. So now that we have
the camera actor, what we are going to do is
from it or simply over here, can I do it like
this set view target with blend, no I cannot I
need to drag a note from the camera actor over
here I need to say set view target actually.
So we need to do this actually from the
Player Controller. So right click over
here we need to say Get Player Controller
and from him. So excuse me for this one.
from him, we need to see set view target with
blend, there you go. So this is where it was.
Unreal Engine has so many functions, sometimes
you forget where they are. So over here, the new
view target is simply going to be we're going to
plug in over here, the camera and everything here
we're going to leave it as is blend times zero
blend function vt blend linear blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah, Compile and Save that. So again,
it's from the Player Controller. So right click,
and over here Get Player Controller This
is how you get the Player Controller.
And over here we have from the Player
Controller, you drag a node you
type set view target with blend, and this is
going to be or this is going to set the view
on the camera that we have specified. And over
here new view target is the camera actor from
the level. So Compile and Save that again.
And if we go back over here in our game plan,
kid the play button, there you go. So this is
this is what we want to see. And this is well
our desired outcome. So if I hit the play button,
now this is our level. So this is how we want to
see it with our main camera moving forward.
Now we are going to start adding elements
inside of our game. So over here inside of the
blueprints first we're going to right click
and go over here under blueprints. And we're
not going to create a blueprint class or
none of these except for the enumeration. So
click on the enumeration and we're going to call
this one food color underscore e num There we go.
So again, it's right click under blueprints and
then enumeration and when you open it over here
what is this well enumeration or enumerators are
basic we can create them however want to create
them. So for example if we click here on new,
you see over here we are going to click on
new and we have a new enumeration and we
can give it a name What whatever we want, and
we are going to create four of these. So the
first enumeration over here is going to be blue.
This is what I meant when I said we can create
however, we want to create them. So we can give
them names, whichever we want. So over here, we
can say purple. For the third one, we can say red.
And for the last but not least, we can say yellow.
And same way you can create I don't know, like,
you can create enumerations for Kenny, Carl,
Johnny, Bobby, whatever, so you can give
them names. And later on inside of our game,
we can use these enumerations to compare
them with each other to basically check if we
have the same item. For example, if the color
of our actor is blue, or purple, or whatever,
we can even use this for tags, we can give them
tags over here, we can compare them later on, so
on and so forth. So this is for what we are using
the enumerations. So the next step, now that we
have the enumeration, we are going to go back over
here, I'm going to right click, and this time,
we are going to create a blueprint class. And it's
going to inherit from the actor. And we're going
to call this bad boy BP food. So we are going to
use this to actually create the food. So I'm going
to double click this, open it of course here in
the Blueprint Editor. Now the first thing that we
are going to do is over here is click on the Add
Component. And we are going to filter for sprite
and we want the paper sprites. So this will be one
of the paper sprite components. If I hover over
you will see it's a paper sprite component. It's a
component that handles rendering and collision for
a single instance of a new paper. Basically, this
is a component where it will allow us to display
an image and I'm going to make it a default
route. And I'm going to rename it to food sprite,
there you go. So I can compile this and save
it. And of course over here inside outside,
of course, like you knew that was coming. So
we're here in the variables, we are going to
create a score variable. And this is going to be
an integer and I am going to make it public and
Compile and Save this bad boy. So this is when
it comes to our food Sprite. Now of course, we
are still not done. Instead, what we are going to
do is we are going to go here in the Event Graph.
And from here, I'm going to remove these
two in the Event Begin Play, we are going to
create a custom function. So right here
below, we are going to get a custom
event and I said function with a custom
event. And we're going to call this set
food. And from here actually First, I'm going to
click on it. And what we are going to have here,
so click on it and over here we're going to have
an input which is a parameter. So we're going to
call it the type and from the drop down list over
here we are going to click here and in the search,
we are going to say food. And there we go. So we
want the food color e&m so this type that we're
going to pass here, inside of this custom event
is going to be the food type enumeration that
we just add it. Now over here when we begin the
event, or will we begin play we're going to call
set food. And let me just find it over here. Where
is it? Where is my custom function, here it is. So
set food. And we are going to leave it at Blue and
pay attention over here because we set the type
over here of this parameter to be the food color
enumeration. You see that we have blue, purple,
red and yellow, which are these over here that
we have created. So we can Compile and Save that
There you go. Now what we are going to do with
this set food is that we are going to get our
food sprite so we are going to put it over here
get it because based on the food we are going to
order based on the color of the food we are going
to change the sprites appearance. So from here
I am going to say switch on first from here from
the type we can say switch and it is going to
create a switch on the food color. And over here
as I said on the food color, we have the blue,
purple, red and yellow, which are the ones that
we have created. So I'm not going to go back again
because we already know that now from here from
the food sprite, I'm going to say set Sprite.
And there you go. Now what I'm also going to do is
copy and paste this, paste it again and paste it
again. So you have four of these possibilities.
When I say possibilities that is we can have
the blue color over here we can have the purple
color, we can have the red color, we can have the
yellow color. Also this food sprite goes into
every single one of these. So make sure that
you do that you can move this a little bit away
like this so that you can see it more clearly.
That's up to you. And there you go. So this
food sprite needs to go in every single one
of these for the target, as you can see,
because we are targeting that food sprite,
now that we have our everything is set up. So
for the switch on the food color, we plugged in
the food sprite over here, when we have the blue
one, we are going to click here and we're going
to select the blue polygon Sprite. Because again,
as I said, if the food if the in among the food is
blue, we are going to set the blue polygon. And
this is what I said a moment ago. So over here,
based on the switch on the enumeration food color,
it is going to tell us if it's blue, then it's
going to execute over here. So if it's blue, it's
gonna execute this if it's purple is gonna execute
this if it's red, this and so on and so forth. So
over here, if it's purple search for purple, there
we go purple polygons right over here, we have the
red, so type red, and we have the red polygon, not
the Red Square, but the red polygon Sprite. And
last but not least over here, we have the yellow.
So over here we have the yellow polygon, Sprite,
there you go. Now what we are also going to do is
we are going to set the score. So over here, set
score, like this, copy and paste this bad boy,
and it does go This goes over here, paste
it one more time, this goes over here.
And last but not least for our yellow, also
paste it like this, this goes over here,
come on, let us go back. There we go. So now over
here, if we have the blue color, we are going to
set the score to be 100. If we have the purple
color, we're going to set the score to be 50.
If we have the red color, we're going to set the
score to 20. And last but not least, if we have
the yellow color, we're going to set the score
to 10. And we can compile and save this. Next,
we are going to wait and delay. So
we're here we're going to delay.
And we are going to delay for three seconds. If
is the blue color copy and paste this and I'm
going to plug it in over here. If it's the purple
color, we are going to delay two seconds. And last
but not least, if it's the red color, we are going
to delay one second. Now we are not going to delay
if we have the yellow color. So we're going
to leave it as is Compile and Save that.
After we delay what we're going to do well
over here, now we're going to set the food
like this, there you go. And we're going to set
the color to purple. And I'm going to copy and
paste this. And this goes over here. And let
me just move these a little bit like this.
And generally move the whole function over here.
There you go. And I say function. It's a custom
event. But it's basically, if not the same thing,
it's similar. And over here we have another set
food and this time this is going to be read. And
last but not least over here we have the food.
And we are going to set this bad boy to yellow
there you go Compile and Save that. So first,
when we go into set food, we are going to go into
switch and we explained this based on the color
we are going to set the sprite of our or the color
of our foods prior to that Sprite. And then we are
going to set the appropriate score based on that
as well. And after that we are going to delay.
Depending on which color we have, we're going to
delay a certain number of seconds. And after that,
we're going to change the color of the sprite
again, so simply Compile and Save this. So this is
for our BP food. Now before we proceed to create
the gameplay mechanic, we still need to create a
couple of more actors over here blueprints.
So we are going to create another blueprint
and it's going to inherit from the actor. And
this one is going to be BP block. There you go.
So double click this bad boy open it over here.
And what's going to happen is we are going to go
again under Add Component and filter for paper
sprite, and it's paper there it goes sprite,
so this will be one and this one is going to be
our block Sprite. What I'm going to do with this
one is over here for the source of the sprite, we
are going to click on the drop down list. And we
are going to filter for gray square sprites.
This is what we want. So this is going to be
a sprite that's going to represent our block
over here for the location for the why we're
going to say minus 10, just so that we can
move a little bit backwards. And we're not
going to touch anything else. So make sure that
you compile and save this as well. There you go.
Moving forward. The next thing is let me go back
over here and right click blueprint class and
again, it's going to inherit from the actor and
this one is going to be BP underscore snake body
part. So there you Go. And what I'm going to
do is double click this bad boy and open it
to open it over here inside of our editor.
Now what's gonna happen with the snake
body part is that we are going to use a paper flip
book. So over here at component, we're going to
filter for paper flip book. And what the hell is a
fake paper flip look, first, let me just set it to
be the default scene. There you go. So we have our
paper flip book, we are not going to add anything
over here inside of our source for it. But over
here for the variables, you're going to click
on the plus button and we are going to see is head
and this one is going to be public. So make sure
that you check this eye box or this eye over here,
so that we can make it public. Because of course,
we want to, you know, access it later on in other
sprites and determine if this is the head or not.
Now what the hell is a paper flip book, paper flip
book in Unreal Engine will allow us to create an
animation and here it is, you see flip books, and
we already have the bait, the beat flip book and
the blank flip book. If I hover over over here, if
I hover over if I right click and go to paper 2d
Here is where you can create a paper flip book.
So it's simply right click paper 2d paper flip
book. And you can call this one test book, for
example. And you can double click on it, and you
can open it here. So what is this what the hell is
this, let me just open the one that we already had
over here, the beeth one, there you go, you see,
and let me just stop it because it is animating.
So this is basically a way inside of Unreal
Engine to animate sprites. And the way this works
is there are multiple ways how you can create
animations like the ones you saw over here, you
can go over here and you can right click to add a
keyframe and there we go, we have a keyframe and
you can right click on that and then over here you
can pick a sprite for example that that sprite one
and you can save that so when you save it and this
is not what I want. So save it if I preview it,
let me see do we see it actually for some
reason we don't so let me just do this.
I am going to close it go back over here and open
it and now we see it. Now you can also do it like
this you can go over here and click c you can move
this handle over here to go at the last frame and
then you can click on add the new frame so now we
have a new frame and again a new frame a new frame
a new frame so we can do it like this as well. And
let me just delete these so we can delete them all
because you can also drag and drop them so the
lead the lead save you can also move this over
here and then from here from your sprites you can
then drop your sprites for example can drop this
one over here or simply over here in the frames
to create an animation you can drop one then
the second and the third and so on and so forth
are over here the new keyframe and you can click
here and pick a dead sprite one image add the new
keyframe right click pick new sprite lets that to
sprite image and let me just save that. So when I
preview it, you see automatically the animation is
being played. So it's a simple, it's very simple.
It's not complicated. getting something is not
clear, make sure that you ask in the comment
below. But basically, you'd simply right click
Add keyframes or click here to add keyframes
and then on those keyframes, you right click and
select the sprites you want so that you can create
the full animation. This is what we did over here.
I already prepared this so that we don't have to
do it. But I explained right now how it is done.
And if I preview it, this is that animation. So
we have 11 sprites or 11 frames. And again, paper
flipbook is a way to animate sprites in Unreal
Engine. So here in the flipbooks weekend, let me
just save everything, we can delete this textbook
because we don't need it anymore. This was just
for an example to show you how it works. And you
can also delete it from here because we don't have
to like we don't need to keep it over here. Again,
if something is not clear about what is a flipbook
and how it works just make sure that you ask in
the comment below the video, let us move on the
main part of our game and here in the blueprints
we are going to right click Create a blueprint
class which is going to inherit from the actor and
this one is going to be BP underscore main game
and I'm going to drag and drop this bad boy in
side of our game now inside of the level that is
and this is we are going to position 000 for all
three axes. But you know it It's not important,
just some I don't know, I'm weird like that I
like to, you know, position things. Anyways,
this is going to be the main blueprint, or
the main actor that is going to control,
initialize and do everything with our game. Now
before we start programming everything over here
in the Event Begin Play, I'm going to remove
everything and over here in the variables,
first, I'm going to click here, and we're going to
have snake parts. So snake parts array, not a rat,
but it's an array like this. And over here, we are
going to search for our snake body parts. So here
BP snake body parts, and I'm going to click here
object reference. Now, as I said, this is going to
be an array, there are two ways how we can declare
an array if you don't know that, so you can click
right click on this blue circle over here, or
you can click on here. And then from there,
you can choose so from here, if I click on you can
see we have a single variable, we have an array,
we have a set, we have a map, we are going to
click here on the right, or as I said over here,
we can right click, so we can right click over
here. And there you go. So when you see these,
like these grids over here, if you didn't know
that this is now an array. Now moving forward,
we are going to click on the plus button, we're
going to have over here direction z, and this
one is going to be an integer and click on the
plus button again, there's going to be direction
x, there you go. So Compile and Save that now
directions in direction x, they are not going
to have any default value. So they're going to
have default values of zero. Moving forward,
I'm going to click here on a new variable, and
we're going to say can change direction, this is
going to determine if we can change the direction
with the snake or not. So Compile and Save that
moving forward, we are going to have x underscore
max. And this one is going to be a float.
And by default, I'm going to set the value of it
to be 1200. And click on the plus again and we're
going to have z underscore Max, make sure that you
Compile and Save that and for the Z, the maximum
is going to be 1000. So for the x max or x maximum
1200 for the Z max, it is going to be 1000.
Moving forward, I'm going to click here and we're
going to have a food actor reference. So food
actor ar e f, and from here I am going to search
for food. And we want the BB food and we want the
object reference Compile and Save that. Moving
forward, we are going to have our wall blocks
array which not again a rat what is what is wrong
with me with the rat. It's an array not on a rat,
anyway is this going to be RBP block. So from
here, click in search or filter for the block.
So this is what we want BP block and just
to be sure BP underscore block here you go
select the object reference and make it an array.
So we want the wall blocks to be an array moving
forward, click on the plus button over here to
add a new variable and this one is going to be
delay not the ol I what I wrote
over here a delay variable which
is going to be a float. So from here we have a
float. Let me just compile this so that I can add
a default value over here so the default value
is going to be point to Compile and Save that.
Moving forward we are going to have another one
which is going to be is dead. And of course you
can assume this is a Boolean because it is
going to determine if the snake is dead or
not. Next we are going to have the HUD r e f or
the reference to our HUD which is going to be
our game Hots over here simply filter for HUD. And
this is what we want BP you I heard and this is
the one that we want which is the one that we have
created. So Compile and Save that moving forward.
Last but not least we are going to have the score
which is going to be an integer so make sure that
you compile and save that as well. So this was
the preparation for our main game blueprint
which is going to control our game. As you can
see over here we have all the variables for the
snake parts we're going to store the snake parts
that we create because you know the snake eats
a jam or eats a fruit or whatever
in the game and then it grows.
Whenever we eat a new item we need to make the
snake large Those parts are going to be stored
inside of this array direction z and x. This is
pretty self explanatory, it's the direction where
the snake is going can change direction can we
you know change the direction self explanatory x,
maximum z maximum, these are the speeds
for the x and the Z we will see later on
how we are going to use that food actor
reference self explainatory wall blogs,
these are the walls that we are going to you know
create like this in the game to strip the movement
of the snake. So, this is the reference where we
are going to put them that the lane is going to be
the speed of the snake we will see later on how we
can increase it is that self explanatory hard self
explanatory score self explainatory. And I don't
think that, you know, we need to explain that
moving forward here in the Event Graph, first,
we are going to right click and create a custom
event. And this custom event is going to be
called spawn new snake part, which is going to do
what the title says or it name says is going to
spawn a new snake part. Now we are going to have
two parameters. So click this new parameter here
on the input two times one, two. So over here,
the first parameter is going to be our spawn
location. And the second parameter is going to be
is head for the spawn location, it is going to be
a vector because vectors represent a location x,
y, and z. Next, what we are going to do
is from here, I'm going to say spawn actor
from class. And the actor that I'm going to spawn
over here, we are going to select the class we are
going to say snake body part. There you go. Now
here we are going to have the spawn transform,
and we have here the location. So what we need
to do is right click on the spawn, transform and
split struct pin so that now we have the spawn
transform location, and I can plug this into the
location, we are not going to touch the Transform,
rotation and scale and so on and so forth.
Over here collision handling override specifies
how to handle commit collisions at the spawn
point. Basically, we are going to click on the
drop down list and we are going to say spawn
always are always spawn ignore a collision. So we
don't we don't care if there are any collisions
at the split space or the spot where
we are going to spawn our snake.
Now moving forward, we are going to drag from
here from the head, we are going to say select
like this, and you want this one over
here, see this one that has this over here,
this like yellowish icon. So that's the one that
you want. So I'm going to do it again select
and here we go, this is the one that we want.
I'm also going to double click here on the pin
so that I can you know, restructure it
like this, I can make this a little bit
clearer, it is better, it looks a little bit
better. And we are going to do it like this.
So there you go. So what we are going to do on
these pin structures is that we are going to
based on what's going to happen over here. So
based on the value if it's true, or if it's false,
I am going to let me just see it like this. So
over here, let me just Compile and Save that.
So this is okay. What we need to do over here is
first drag from the drag from the paper flip book.
And for some reason the target over here needs
to have it so we're going to get the paper flip
book. Let me just see it over here. Here it is the
paper flip book from the returned value which is
basically let me just go over here and this thing
body parts This is that paper flipbook. So we are
going to get that paper flip book and we are going
to from here we're going to say set flip book.
There you go. And we are going to set this the
return value, we're going to plug it in over here
as soon as we plug it in. As soon as this value
is plugged in over here, the true and the false
will automatically give us it will give us an
option to select a paper flipbook. So I'm going
to plug this in there you go, bam, you see right
there. And let me just move this here. There you
go. This goes over here like that. So if the is
head, if it's false, we are going to select the
yellow square flipbook. So this is the one that we
want. If it's true, we are going to select the Red
Square flipbook and we are going to Compile and
Save So again, if it's false, we are going to
select the yellow square flipbook. So yellow
square foot book. If it's true, we are going
to select the Red Square flipbook. So if it's
a head, it's going to be represented with red.
And this is what we are going to do. Now the next
part or the next step that we are going to do is,
after we set the flipbook, we are going to get the
snake parts array. And we are going to from here,
create a node and we're going to say add, which is
going to add to this, it is going to add to this
array. Now we need to add a new element, the new
element is going to be the returning value over
here that we have created from our spawn snake
body part. So I'm going to take this return value
and plug it in over here. But before that, I am
also going to double click on that, no, then move
it like this and double click on the node again
so that I can you see it so that I can create like
this. And now we see that it goes, the node goes
from here to here, and then goes over here to add
it into the snake parts array, which is what we
want. Now the next step that we are going to do is
from here, from this one, we are going to say set
is head, and that goes over here. And again, I'm
going to double click on the node just so that it
is more visual, visually clear what we are doing.
And here is head we're going to plug in this one.
And again, I am going to double click on this node
and move it over here like this, we can clearly
see this goes from here his head, and then we're
going to plug it in over here and then it goes
from here over here. And we're going to plug it in
and set it to the node if it's a head or not. So
now moving forward, we are again going to drag
from this node, which is again the snake body part
that we have created because now we are going to
set the actor or rotation for the snake body part,
this goes over here and then we double click again
on the node itself. This goes over here. And in
order to set the rotation for our snake, what I'm
going to do is I'm going to get a random integer.
And this random integer is going to have maximum
of three because over here, if I hover over
returns and uniformly distributed random number
between zero and maximum minus one, so we can get
well as you can see, so zero maximum minus one,
what we are going to do over here is we
are going to plug this into a select.
And there you go. So we have now the Select over
here, I am going to add two more pins. So we have
options 012 and three, and option one First things
first, I'm going to split the pin structure here
for the rotation. So split struct pin. And we
are going to plug in the return value over here
inside of the why for the pitch. And
when you do that automatically, these
options that are going to convert into integer
actually float values. So when I plug it in bam,
they have converted into float values when we
have option while we're going to say zero when we
have option two, we are going to say 90 degrees.
Option actually options here, option one is 90,
option two is 180. And option three is 270. And we
are going to Compile and Save that. And if you're
wondering why I added option three, well maybe you
decide to later on add here maximum for four. And
there you go. So Compile and Save that this is
going to be our spawn new snake and I'm going to
put it in a comment, right click Create a
comment from section I'm going to say over here,
spawn new snake part there you go, Compile
and Save that. Next we want to spawn our food.
And in order to spawn the food, the first
thing that we are going to do is this,
we are going to get our x maximum and we're going
to get our z maximum, we're going to put them
over here. Now what's going to happen is for
the x maximum, I'm going to say minus float.
And the float that I'm going to subtract it or
subtract from it is going to be 100. So 100. Next,
what I'm going to do is from here, I'm going
to multiply this with a float. So I'm going to
multiply this with a float, the float that I'm
going to use to multiply is going to be negative
one. And the reason for that is because you see
subtraction, A minus B, the return value over here
is actually the result from this. So I'm going to
multiply the result with negative one, because I
am going to use over here a random, random float
in range. And the minimum is going to be this
value multiplied by negative one and the maximum
is going to be this value. Let's assume z or x
maximum. Well actually it's 1002 100 minus 100, we
are left with 1100 multiplied with negative one,
we have negative 1100. And over here we have the
positive 1100. Next, what I'm going to do is from
here, I'm going to right click, and I'm going to
say division, and we want the division with the
whole and remote remainder. The You see, if I
hover over returns, the number of times divisor
will go into the dividend. So the divisor is this
number that we have over here, it will return how
many times this number goes into this number.
dividend is this number over here, the last the
random float in range, and the divisor is going to
be 100. So this is going to return how many times
divisor goes into the dividend, it is going to
return the value over here, but the remainder is
how much did it remain from the dividend.
For example, let's say the dividend is 1050.
The divisor is 100, it goes 10 times into
1050. So the return value here, we'll say
it goes 10 times inside, but what's remaining
is 50. Because 10 multiplied by 100 is 1000
1050 minus 1000, we are left with 50. And this
is what we are doing over here. Now last but not
least, we're going to take that return value
and multiply it with a float. And that float
is going to be 100. Now we are still not done, we
are going to go back over here for our x maximum.
And here we're going to say minus float and do
the same thing. So minus float, the minus value
is going to be 100. And over here, we're going
to multiply that with a float. So multiply that
with a negative value over here. So we are
going to say minus one random float in range,
this is going to be plugged in over here, this is
going to be plugged in over here, basically doing
the same thing. So we can copy these two and
paste them over here because the return value
goes into the dividend. And over here we have 100
for the divisor, and we're going to multiply this
with 100 as well. Because now over here, I'm going
to right click, and I'm going to create a custom
event. And this custom event is going to be
called spawn food. And from here, I am going to
say spawn actor from class. And the class that
I'm going to use is the BP food or simply type
food. And there you go. Now what we are also
going to do is for the transformer going to
split the struct pin, but I'm also going
to do that over here for the location,
right click on the location and split struct pin,
because now I can plug in this one on the x. And
I can plug in this one on the location z and the
location y is going to be equal to negative 0.1.
Because we are this is a 2d game. And we have
the x and the Z. So over here, x and the Z and Y
is basically to move it backwards like this. So
we don't care about why. And for the collision
handling, we are going to say always spawn,
ignore collisions, and you can Compile and
Save that. And of course, the last step over here
is that we need to set the set food actor AR F.
So we are going to set the reference to
the food actor because later on we need to
test if our snake is colliding with the food
actor. And I'm going to right click and create
a comment over here and this was going to
be spawn food and make sure that you compile
and save that as well. Now what is happening over
here? Well basically again, we are just doing some
basic calculations over here from the x maximum
and the Z maximum. So that we can as you can see,
x maximum is 100 or 1200. And the Z maximum is
1000. Now why is that if I go back over here,
and let me just take a sprite and let's say this
is the food and this is where we can put the foot
pay attention to the x value over here. It's
at 1000, negative 1180. And on the z axis,
if I move it down like this, it goes to negative
900 or negative 1000 here is the positive 1000.
So this is basically what we are doing.
And again, if you are wondering why am
I subtracting 100 from that because again, if
I said the Z to 900, you see it's right over
here at the top. So this is what we are doing.
So there you go, and this is why so basically,
we are going to use the these values to randomly
So again, it's these values to randomly spawn our
food within these bounds because As you can
see, if I go over here, if I select the food,
and if I go over here, this goes up to negative
1000. You see 1100. This is where it goes,
if I move a little bit here towards the edge, it's
negative 1170. If it goes over here, it's positive
1000. So there you go, is going to spawn it
within those bounds. Basically, this is what we
are doing. Did I move this by any chance? I don't
think I did. I don't think that the negative 50
minus 10, minus 50. Yeah, that's okay. 12
to 1210. Yeah, that's okay. That's okay.
So yeah, we are again, these values are going to
randomize and spawn our food within that range
that we just saw. So this is what we are
doing. And now that you know that you can
easily calculate or see which numbers are going to
basically this is going to return a random number
between negative 101,100 and positive 1100.
And this is going to do the same thing,
but for the Z max, but because
the max is 1000 is going to return
a random number between negative 900 and positive
100. There you go. Positive 900. Excuse me.
Anyways, moving forward, I'm going to right
click here and create another Custom Event.
And this custom event is going to be called
kill snake, which is basically going to do the
killing of a snake symbol going forward,
you're going to set that is that
and is that is going to be true. So
make sure that you said that over here.
After we set the snake to be dead, we
are going to take the snake body parts.
And we are going to right click over here. And
we're going to say for each loop, because we want
to loop through each element inside of this array,
I'm going to plug this in over here and the array
that we're going to loop is going to be the snake
parts array. Now what's going to happen over here
is that in the loop body part or loop body, we are
going to set the from the array element, I'm going
to get the paper flip book. So let me just get it
here it is get the paper flip book because we know
that the snake body part has a paper flip book.
And from here I'm going to say set flip book.
Here it is. So this goes inside of our
loop bodypart There you go. So every loop,
we are going to set the paper flipbook,
and we're going to use the array index,
and we're going to say e select on it, there
you go. And based on the options, we are going
to our actually let me just remove this we are
going to take the array index and we're going to
test that if it's equal to zero. And based on the
options over here, we're going to say East select
now on this Boolean. And let me just move this
over here. And I'm going to plug in the Boolean
over here, which is going to give us the options
to if it's false. We are going to select the beat
flipbook. If it's true, we are going to select
the blank flipbook. What this means. Basically,
in our snake body part, the first element that's
inside of the array is going to be the head. So
what we are going to do over here, if the array
index is equal to zero, that means it's true.
So we have the head for the head, we
are going to use the blank flip book,
because the head is not going to explode like
this flip book over here. Basically, this is
the animation for this flipbook. So this is how we
are going to animate the flip book for the snake
body part. It's like you know it's dissolving,
it's going away, this is what we are doing.
So if the element is if the array element index
is zero, meaning it's the head, then we're going
to use the blank. If it's false, it's not the head
then we're going to use the beat flipbook. This is
what we are doing now when it's completed when all
of this completes, and I'm going to move this over
here. So when it's completed, when the looping
completes, we're going to go inside of the delay,
and over here the delay is going to be point five
of a second so we are going to wait half a second
and after that we are going to go inside of
for each loop again, for snake parts array
again. So over here, get the snake parts array,
and we are going to go in the for each loop.
We are going to loop through this snake parts
array again and this time we are going to
set every paper flip book so the loop body part
from the target. We're going to get the paper flip
book, which is this one over here, get the paper
flip book. And over here we're going to say set,
Phillip book. Here you go. This goes over here.
We're going to plug it in and this time we are
going To set the blank flipbook. So here it is,
for every single one of these when it finishes.
Why? Well, because we want to simply, we want to
simply make the snake disappear when we set the
blank flip book. And if you go back over here,
if you selected in the blank flipbook, there is
nothing, which means nothing will be represented
in our, in the snake. So the snake will simulate
disappearance, this is what we are doing. And I'm
going to right click over here, I'm going to say
kill snake. If something is not clear, make
sure that you ask but basically going through
this again, when we call the kill snake event,
we're going to set the is that to true, then
we're going to loop through the snake parts array.
And if the index is equal to zero, that means it's
the head if that is true, set the blank flipbook
so that the head is not visible. If it's false,
it's not the head, it's the rest of the
parts of the snake then set the beat,
which is going to preview this animation that
we already saw. And when the loop completes,
and when we loop through every single element
in that array, we're going to wait half a second
and then loop through the snake parts array
again, and this time for every single element
inside of our array, we are going to set the
blank flip book, which is going to make the
snake not visible and look like we killed it in
the game. Last part for our custom event, we are
going to create your custom event and this one is
going to be update score there you go over here,
the score is going to have a parameter
which is going to be the value,
we know it's the value and the value is going to
be an integer, Compile and Save that. So now we
are going to take the score over here get the
score. And this video we are going to say plus
integer, so we are going to add these two.
So we are going to add to the value that we
pass over here the current score value. And
after that, we are going to set the score.
So set the score and plug this in over here for
the new value. And after that we're going to
get the HUD Reference that we will create in a
moment. Don't worry about that. And over here,
we're going to say update score. And this
goes over here. And this goes over here.
There you go. If you're wondering what is this
update score, simply double click it go over here.
And you can see, we are going to have the score
value over here. And we're going to plug it into
the score text that we already explained inside
of our UI, HUD, which is going to display the
score to our user. And this is how we are doing
it. So we are going to pass the value over here.
add to it, the current value of the score said
the new score value passes through the update
score function of the HUD Reference, make sure
that you compile and save that and let me just
right click over here create a comment and this
one is going to be update score. Again, if it's
not something it's not clear, but this should
be self explanatory because this is not complex
at all. But ask in the comment below. If it's not
clear, and I will explain it. Now we can start
adding all of these features in our game. And
first, you're going to start over here with the
Event Begin Play. And inside of our Event Begin
Play, the first thing that we are going to do is
we are going to create the HUD digit, and we are
going to do it like this, we're going to right
click, and then we are going to see, say over here
Create Widget. But before we proceed, I'm going to
right click on this node. And I'm going to click
here to collapse notes. There you go. And now that
is collapse. I'm going to call this node create
herd widget. Now what the hell is this collapse?
No. Basically, when we click in here, this is
where the action happens inside the Think of this
as a function. That's the best way to explain
it, we group nodes inside of this collapse graph,
so that they don't take too much space over here.
So if I double click this, what we need to do is
put this place this node on the input over here
now and when I compile and save that and go back,
you will see now that we can drag a note on this
collapse graph like this. And if you're wondering
how I'm going back and forth, well, I double
click this to open it over here. But in order to
go back, you're going to click this back button,
which is right there. Now over here, I'm going to
select the BP UI HUD that we want to create. After
that we are going to set our HUD Reference. I'm
going to drag the note for that. So we're going
to set it this is the HUD Reference. There you go.
And last but not least, we need to add
it to Viewport so we need to say Add to
Viewport And who are we adding to the
viewport? Well we're adding our HUD
And last but not least drag this node on the
output to create the output line node but
you can also do is Over here, right click,
and over here you see, I can go back and I
can click in here instead of then I can say, for
example, next or something like that you can see,
it's renamed to next meaning what is the next
thing that we will do if you click over here, for
the input that says execute, you can do something
like do or whatever. But you can see over here do
and then it continues the execution. So again,
this collapse, no does he do and then next,
basically, you don't have to do that. But you can,
it's not mandatory, it will not change the game,
it will not do anything. But you know, if for
your own reference, if you want to do that,
you can. But again, this collapse graph allows
us to group all of these inside of the single
graph. So instead of having three of these, so
three of these over here, we only have this one
collapse graph. So the next step is to get a
random integer. So I'm going to say random int.
And I'm going to right click on it and collapse
the note. And I'm going to call this one select.
So this is going to be select random direction
random start start direction. And before we
actually proceed on this one, we can test the UI
widget if it works. So let me just go quickly back
over here, if I hit the play button, make sure you
see over here we have this score, we don't see the
game over tab, or the game over panel because
it is down there. So it's down there when the
snake dies, we will see it. But what you need to
do in order to have this if you don't see it, you
need to drag from the blueprints, you need to drag
the BP main game over here in the level so that it
is over here visible in the world outliner. If
you don't do that, then when you run the game,
you will not see this score, and so on and so
forth. So if I go back over here, now we have the
Select random starts direction. And what we are
going to do over here is from the random integer,
I'm going to set the value to be three.
And what I'm going to do is do us switch
on this int some way to say the word shits
like this switch on integer, there you go,
I'm going to plug this into the input over here,
and we're going to have 1234. And this default I
am going to remove so we have these from zero
up to three. Now what's gonna happen is, if we
have zero, we're going to say set direction x. And
from here, the direction x is going to be one. And
I'm going to copy and paste it because if we have
one, we are going to have the set direction x but
this time direction x is going to be negative one.
from two, we are going to have set directions z,
which is going to be equal to one and copy
and paste it again from three over here,
we are going to have our direction z, which is
going to be minus one. Simple as that. And now
we are going to drag all of these nodes. So
from here, plug it in like this, and I can do
something like this, double click on the node.
So now we can plug all of these nodes over here
in this single dot, which means over here in the
input, we go and we get into the switch integer
based on the random value of 301. And three, we
are going to select the random direction x to be
one, or minus one, or Z to be one or minus one.
And after that we are going to go into the output,
make sure that you Compile and Save that. So now
we can plug in this over here. And we can continue
the execution because the next step is to get
our delay. So from here delay, I'm going to set
it I'm going to right click on it and collabs
the nodes and this one is going to be set
up date delay in parentheses, Snake speed, because
as I said, if you remember, the delay is the snake
speed. So this goes over here, this goes over
here and the speed of the snake is going to be
point two in the beginning. And I'm going
to compile and save that and go back over
here, plug this in. And as I said, this serves
a weight as a way for us to group our nodes. And
you can think of it as a function, which means
that basically, the execution goes like this,
the Event Begin Play begins it goes over here
inside of this create UI widget collapse graph
inside it is going to create the widget, set a
reference to it, add it to viewport and then exit
outside of that collapse graph. And then from
here, when it exits, it's gonna go inside of this
collapse graph and execute everything in there and
then from there, exit and I entered this one and
so on and so so forth. So this is what we are
doing over here. The next step is to spawn the
snakes head. So over here, what we need to do is
get the snake parts array. And I'm going to right
click on it and collapse the graph. And I'm going
to call this one spawn snake head, there you go.
inside of this bad boy, we are first going to
clear this array. So we are going to say clear,
which is basically going to remove every element
from this array. In case we have it but we don't
but you know, just as a precaution, we are going
to clear everything. And after that, we are going
to say over here, spawn new snake part. There you
go. And I'm going to plug this in over here. So
it's going to pause, spawn the snake part, and I'm
going to click here is head to denote that it's
a head, the spawn location can be 000. And over
here, now this goes over here, so that execution
flow continues. And next we are going to spawn
our food. And in order to do that, I'm simply
going to right click over here and say spawn food.
Now we can leave it like this. But since we are
doing these collabs graphs, just to you know,
be consistent, I'm going to put it in the graph
and I'm going to say spawn, first food, there
you go, double click it. This goes over here.
And this goes over here, and I can Compile
and Save that. And if I go back, plug this in,
there you go. I can compile and save this as
well. And we can test this spawn first food and
snakeheads if I go back, if I hit the play button,
there you go. So over here we have our food.
And you can see the food is changing also.
But for the snakehead, let me just go back
quickly over here, spawn snake had. So over
here spawn new snake, it's a head and we left
everything as is so basically 000 snake parts
array. Let me just double click this bad boy.
spawn new snake part at the location. Okay,
so this is what I've missed. As you can see,
from here, I didn't drag the execution to this
to set it the flipbook stupid, stupid. I know.
But as I said, there we go. So this will fix our
issue. So drag the node from here to here. This
is what I forgot, then you probably saw that then
you were like, stupid teacher. And yes, I am. But
as I said, anyways, there you go. So let me just
Compile and Save that we can go back out side
of here now and Compile and Save again, compile,
then save. If I go back and hit the play button,
we should see the snake as well. Here it is. This
is our sneaky, sneaky sneaky. And we also have our
foodie foodie foodie. And there you go. Of course
the snake will start moving, but at the moment,
it will not start to move because we still didn't
program that but every single time we click the
play button, they are going to be spawned within
these bounds because that's why we have the
maximum x and the maximum if I go back the x max
and the Z max. So that is for the to put them
inside of these bounds. Anyways, moving forward.
The last part over here is we are going to right
click and I'm going to create a for loop and
every single time I write for a loop with two O's,
so for loop not for each loop but for loop,
right click collapse and know that this one
is going to be spawn walls and double click it.
So what's gonna happen is I'm going to plug this
in like this, the execution goes over here, the
first index is going to be zero so we're going
to loop from zero. But next what we are going to
do over here and I'm going to put this over here,
then we will move it if there is a need to do that
I'm going to get the x maximum and the Z maximum.
Now for the x maximum, what I'm going to do is we
are going to go inside of our division hole and
remainder I'm going to copy and paste it because
we're going to need it for the Z maximum as well.
So the x maximum is going to go eat to the
dividend and the divisors value is going to be 50.
And basically these can go a little bit away
from here something like this. So dividend
is the x maximum divisor is 50. We explain
what this is. Next here for the return value
we are going to say multiplied with integer.
Now what we are going to multiply is we are
going to multiply the return value from here so
this goes over here, and this goes over here.
And also z maximum goes into the dividend
and the divisor is going to be 50 as well.
So what's gonna happen next is from
here I am going to say minus into
And the value is going to be one, so I'm going to
subtract it from one and that is going to be our
last index over here. And I can move this a little
bit over here. So what's happening over here
basically, for our what's happening for the last
index, or how many times you're going to loop is
we are taking the x maximum and z maximum, we are
setting them to be dividends, and the divisor is
50. And you know, I told you that the return value
is returns the number of times divisor would go
into the dividend. So if the divisor is 50, and
the dividend is 200, for example, divisor will
go four times into 200. Because 50 and 50 is 150
is 150, and 50 is 200. That means four times 50
can go into 200. And what's remaining is zero,
this goes until what's remaining is zero, or the
number that has remained is not the divisor bowl
with the divisor. Because for example, if we have,
let's say, 210, and we use the divisor 50. So how
many times 50 goes into 210, it goes four times,
because four multiplies by 50 is 200, what's
left, it's 10 1050, cannot go into 10. So that's
not possible. So there, this operation will stop.
From here, we are doing the same thing for the Z,
and then we're using and we're multiplying these
two values, the return values and subtracting one
from them. And we're setting that as the last
index. Now, what's gonna happen over here
is that we are going to move the output a
little bit over here, what I'm going to do is,
I am going to take this index from the loop,
and we are going to divide an integer. And the
integer that's going to be divided by this
number, or this number is going to be divided
by the return value from here. So I'm going
to plug it in, so the return value goes there.
Also, what we are going to do is from here
from this pin, actually, from the return value,
that is from the return value over here for the x
maximum. And let me just move this over here, move
these two over here so that we can see clearly
what they're doing. So from here, I'm going to
say minus integer. And the number that we're going
to use to subtract from it is going to be one.
And from here, I'm also going to take the index
and I'm going to use the modulus. So this is
modulus which is basically the same operation
as this one over here for the division. And the
divisor is basically going to tell us how many
times this number goes into this number over
here. So how many times and we are going to set
the return value from here. So basically, how many
times the return value from this value is going
to go inside of the index. There you go. Now,
also, what we are going to do from here
is again, we are going to subtract,
so we are going to see minus integer, and the
value that we are going to subtract is going to be
one. So what we are going to do with all of
these, well, let's go here on the top, the first
thing that we are going to do from this one, I'm
going to test if it's equal to from here, we are
setting if it's equal to zero, and from here,
we are going to say if it's equal to as well.
But here we're going to test if it's equal to the
value that we have over here. And now I'm going to
save or because we are going to test these Boolean
so or if this Boolean is true, or this Boolean is
true, or this Boolean is true, and we're going
to have one more, then this whole value is going
to be equal to true. But before we proceed to
do that over here, I'm going to test if this
one is equal to zero, the one with the modulus
operator and I'm going to plug this in over here.
And last but not least, we're going to test if
these two are equal as well. So if this goes
over here, if they are equal, this one goes in
the last plug in over here. And this one goes
inside of the condition. And that condition, let
me just do it something like this. There we go.
This goes into the branch from the loop There
go the loop goes inside of our branch and I'm
going to move this over here. The condition
goes over here now. And what's gonna happen
next is I'm going to take the x maximum again.
So from here, I'm going to get the x maximum.
Actually from here, x max on here it is get x max.
And from here, I'm going to multiply it with a
float. and the value of that float is going to be
one or actually negative one. Excuse me for that
for Our operation over here that we use to divide,
we are going to multiply that with a float.
And that float value is going to be 100. So we're
here, it's 100. Why it's giving me so 100. And now
from here, we are going to add these
two. So we're going to say plus float.
plug this in over here. And this is going to be
our value that we are going to use over here to
spawn actor from class. There you go. This goes
over here. If it's true, this goes over here,
the execution continues in the output. But from
here, we're going to spawn the wall blueprint.
Actually, the brick, excuse me, how did I name
the block, excuse me, it's not the brick, but the
block. There you go. So BP block. From here, we're
going to say try to adjust location. So we are
going to say try to adjust location don't spawn
if colliding. So let me just see, try to adjust.
There you go. This right here specifies height to
handle and we talked about that. So it was it is
going to try to adjust the location so that every
block is pond like this right next to each other.
And it's not going to you know, it's don't spawn
if it's still colliding. So basically, if they're
colliding with each other like this, they are
not going to be spawn over here from the spawn
transfer, I'm going to split the pin structure and
also here for location split the pin structure,
this one goes into the spawn exposition.
Now we are also going to have for the Z
position. So over here, what I'm going to do
is move this like this, this goes over here,
I'm going to get the Z maximum. And for the Z
max, and I'm also going to multiply that float
like this. Going back over here with minus one,
Next, we are going to take this value that we have
here from the modulus operator, and we are going
to multiply that with a float and that float value
is going to be 100. Same as what we did here for
the x above, so 100. Now from there, we are going
to add these two together. So we're going to say
plus float, this goes over here. And this float
last but not least goes inside of the Z position
Compile and Save that now this is probably,
you know too much what we did. So what's happening
over here is that we are using the division, the
divisions for the whole and remainder. To set the
last index, we explain what this here is, after
that we are using these operations with divide
minus modulus and minus again, with the index
over here from the loop body because that index is
the current value of the index that we have over
here, which is going to be divided with the return
value from the for the z axis, it is also going to
be used here for the modulus for the z axis as
well. And we're going to compare all those values
if this is equal to zero, if these two are equal,
if this from here is equal to zero, and if these
two are equal, and we're going to plug them
into the OR operator condition or test for the
boolean value, which means if this Boolean so if
this is true, or this is true, or this is true,
this is true, then this whole thing is true, we
only need one of these to be true to for this to
work. So that goes into the branch over here, if
it's true, we are going to spawn the actor block,
and over here, the position x so the location x
and the locations, you are going to use that by
using the x maximum multiplying it with the
negative because when we multiplied with the
negative, we are going to spawn them over here in
over here, because the negative values are here
on the edges. So that's why we're multiplying
that with the negative same thing we're doing
over here. Next, we are using this value that
we got from dividing the index with the return
value from the xemacs. So we're using that value,
multiplying it by 100. And adding to it adding to
add this value over here. This is going to be the
location x. Doing the same thing for the locations
the multiplying with the negative because we
want to put it on the edge moving forward the
value we got here from the modulars we are going
to multiply with the 100 and then add these two
and this one goes into the locations and of course
from here, it goes into the output or actually I
don't think we need to do that. We don't need
to add To the output, we can even break this,
because we don't have any more operations
over here. So from here, we don't have any
more operations, this goes over here, but you
can leave it like that it's not important. But
what we need to do is this. From here, we do need
to take these walls, so we need to take the wall
block array. And from here, we need to say
ad, which is going to add every single time
this new block that is created. And no, that's not
what we want. This goes over here. There we go.
And this goes over here, Compile and Save that.
And from here, you can go in the output. But as I
said, you don't have to do that, because we don't
have an output. We don't have any more executions
going from here. But I mean, you can leave it
like that it's not important at all, it will not
affect our game. But what's important is that we
do this, as you can see, we need to take the wall
blocks array, and every single time we create
here, a new block actor, we need to put it inside
of this array, because later on, we're going to
test if the snake is colliding with those blocks
by comparing them to the position of every
block in the array, we will see that later on.
So Compile and Save that then make sure that from
here from the spawning for his food, you plug the
execution order over here. As I said, this is not
important, this other execution order over here.
So this one, it's not important, but you can,
you know, leave it like that it's not important.
Going back, we can go here in the gameplay,
if I hit the play button. Now there we go.
And thanks to this pay attention over here, let
me just try to use shift and f1 to eject myself.
And if I come close, you will see that these
blocks are not colliding with each other, they are
exactly put together on like their, you know, like
this, I don't know how to explain it. So they're
exactly right next to each other, they're
forming a whole view over here or a whole,
there's no space between them. But they're
still not colliding with each other, which
This over here is going to help us achieve that
what we said try to adjust location, don't spawn
if still colliding, there you go. So we can try
this one more time. So Compile and Save that just
so that we can see it actually works. If I hit the
play button, there you go. So these are the walls
that are going to be the bounds where the snake
will be able to move. And if it hits those bounds,
then well, the snake is going to die moving
forward. Let us go back here in our main game.
So now we have everything over here set up, I
can select all of this here. And we can put in
a comment like initialize game or something like
that. And every single time I make a mistake, so
it's lowercase a even though that's not important,
but I'm crazy. And I have to you know, redo it
anyways, moving forward, I'm going to right click
over here and we are going to search for our tic
event. And why well, because in the TIC event is
where the magic is going to happen. First things
first, we are going to get our is dead. So we
are going to get it and right click and collapse
the notes. And over here, we're going to call
this one check for that collision or actually
condition one, there you go. From here, what
we are going to do is you're going to take our
is that variable and we are going to go inside of
a branch. And I'm going to plug this in over here.
And then what we are going to do is you're going
to plug in both of these true and false in the
output. So it goes over here and it goes over
here. So now we have true and false. And what
we can do is over here you can change these names
for true you can say is that for example and for
false, you can say is not that so that when we go
back now over here, pay attention so I can plug in
and now we have two execution orders that we can
use. So we have is that and is not that meaning
when we check over here the condition is that
if it's true, it will return over here true. If
it's false, it will return over here false. So we
have two ways if it's true, if the player is dead,
we can do whatever we want over here if he is
not that we can do whatever we want over there.
So what we are going to do, well we are going
to and let me just move this a little bit down
then we can move it up again just so that
we can then more clearly see these notes.
First I'm going to get the input r so let me
just find it over here. Where is the R button
rrr Here it is. Now what we are going to
do with the R button is we are going to
Create a sequence. But for that we are going to
actually not a sequence but a collabs graph. But
for that, we're going to get a gate. And for here
for this gate, I'm going to collapse the node and
I am going to call this one restart sequence.
There you go. Now what we are going to do is
we are going to have when we entered the gate, so
we're here we are going to have when we enter and
when we have opened the gate. So over here, as you
can see, enter and open Compile and Save that. So
now what we are going to do over here, and let
me just go back is that if the player is that,
we're going to go over here to enter in the
sequence, or basically enter in this gate.
And when we are going to open the gate is when
we press the R button, but let me just move this
a little bit up, and our button is here. And when
we press the R button, we are going to open this
gate. So again, as you can see over here, when
the player is that we are going to go and enter
inside of the gate, when do we open the gate when
we press the R button. Now what does that mean?
This gate, if I hover over allows for opening
and closing a gate to control the execution flow.
When we enter the gate, it doesn't mean
that we will execute what's after over
here only when we open the gate, then
it then that is when we are going to
that is when we are going to execute what's over
here, but we cannot open the gate if we don't
enter it. So we are gonna enter the gate when
the player dies. We know over here we tested this
condition. So if the player is dead, we are going
to enter this gate. But we only open it when we
press the R button before we open it, it will not
do anything. And even if we try to open it without
entering the gate, it will not work. So think
of this as a control for the execution flow.
So what's going to happen when we enter and
open the gate from here we are going to do once.
And the name says it all output fires only the
first time the node is hit, but can be reset.
What's important over here is that we
know that this will only execute once
so we can only press the R button once to
execute everything that is over here. Which
means now we can take the HUD Reference.
And from here I can remove from parent.
So we can remove from from parent this widget.
There you go because we already have one.
And actually, when we start the game are going to
create a new one. So that's why we can remove the
old one from our from the current parent. Next,
what we can do is we can get the current level
name. And this is going to give us the name of the
current level we are in because we want to reload
that same level. And next we are going to
open the level. So we're going to say open
level here. And I'm going to plug this in over
here. And last but not least plug this in over
here and it is going to convert because this
returns a string and over here we need the name.
So this is going to convert a string to a name
value the output we don't need to touch it because
well, there is nothing more that we are going to
do over here. Basically if the player is dead,
and then we just go back. So if the player is
that this is only what we are going to execute
when the player presses the R key, he is going to
restart the game same as what we saw in side of
our preview, when I say the preview, I mean the
preview of the game when we first started it. So
there you go, this is what's gonna happen here. If
the player is not that what's gonna happen First
things first, we are going to wait and in order
to wait we are going to get the delay from here,
I'm going to right click and collapse the nodes
and this one is going to be called wait. And
what's gonna happen is we are going to call the
delay function. So over here called the delay,
this goes over here and the duration is going
to be the delay itself or the value of the delay
when it's completed. We are going to go here
in the output meaning we are going to continue
the execution order and what did I do over
here let me just go back there you go. So,
if the player is not that we are going to wait for
the specified time that we just saw for our snake
and when we wait after that, what we
are going to do is we are going to go
inside of sequence now what is a sequence so
how did I read it see Quinn's There you go.
Now what is the sequence first I'm going to right
click and collapse the node and this one is going
to be sequence one. What's going to happen over
here is that we are going to enter in the sequence
and we are going to put put this over here and put
this over here and what we are going to say over
here for them Zero, we are going to say do first.
And for the den one, we're going to say do second.
Now a sequence, if I hover over, it says executes
a series of pins in order, meaning it will first
execute this over here. And then it will execute
this over here. And if we have more pins, you can
click here plus to add more pins, then it will
execute the other pins in order. In this case,
what we did over here is that so this goes
over here like this. First, we will do what's
in this sequence. And then we will do what's in
this sequence. And whatever we put over here,
it will not be executed. Until this first one
over here finishes, because is the first one.
So what's going to happen is that we are going
to let me just Compile and Save that first,
I'm going to get the snake parts array,
and I'm going to right click on it collabs,
the node and this one is going to be called
check head self collision, this is basically
going to check if the snake collides with its
own head. So what we are going to do over here,
for the input output, we're going to move a
little bit away because over here, I'm going to
right clip, right click, and I'm going to see for
each loop with the break. Now what is the break,
this goes over here, by the way, the array
goes over here, break is we can call break,
to break out the loop. So it doesn't matter.
For example, if this snake parts has, you know,
30 elements, that means the loop will loop 30
times, we can call break to break up that loop
on the I don't know, let's say 10th loop, so it
doesn't have to loop 30 times if we find what we
need. Now how does that work? Well over here,
I'm going to create a custom event. So Custom
Event. And I'm going to call this bad boy brake
self collision test loop. And simply from there,
we are going to plug this in over here in
the brake and there we go. So when we call
this custom event, it is going to break out of
the loop. So what's going to happen over here
is going to happen that output when this
completes, we are going to plug in the
output so when it completes, this is going to
go in the output meaning we are going to go let
me just Compile and Save that we are going
to go and continue the execution from here.
But what's going to happen in the loop body first
in the loop body, we are going to go inside of
our branch. And the condition for the branch is
going to be the array index and I'm going to test
if it's not equal to zero. So if the index is not
equal to zero, that's going to be our condition.
Now the reason for that is because while for
the first head, we cannot check if the head is
colliding with itself because the snake has a
head then it has you know the body like this.
So there you go, there you go, there you go.
We can we cannot check if this head collides
with Excel because it's not possible, we only can
check if it collides with one of these body parts.
So what's gonna happen over
here is from the array element,
from this array element, I am going to get
the actor location like this. And I'm going to
move this over here and get it like this. There
you go. So we will need our accurate location,
we will also need our snake Bart's array from
here and we are going to get so we're going to
get a copy and we're going to get the element
that's an index zero meaning that's the head
of the snake. And from the head of the
snake, we are going to get the actor
location like this. So we have now two locations.
Again over here this is going to execute,
the branch is going to execute only
if the index is not equal to zero,
so we can rest assured that the array element we
get over here, and the actor location is not the
location of the element that's at the index zero
meaning not the location of the head, but over
here we're getting the location of the head. And
why do we need that? Well, now I'm going to equals
equals test these two vectors if they are equal
with the tolerance 0.001 meaning do they overlap
is the head of the snake. So for example, this
is the head of the snake, this is the body
this is the Body Body buddy buddy, buddy buddy
body so on and so forth. And this is the head
so we can test if this location of this head
is for example same as the location of this and
that can only happen if like this. So this is the
head of the snake and the snake goes for example,
like this, as you can see and then down over
here or here, over here, over here and over here
and over here. So over here is where the head
would collide with one of the body parts and this
is what we are doing. So if this is true, we are
going to go inside of another branch and inside of
this branch, we are going to test or plug in this
condition, meaning we are testing if the body part
that is at the current index does it collide
with the head of the snake. If that is true,
then we are going to go over here and we are going
to call kill snake event, which we already know we
created this in the previous video. So here it is,
our custom kill snake event which is going to set
is that the true for each loop is going to go
here and we explain everything what is going
on. So kill the snake. Next, we are going to get
the HUD Reference. And from the HUD Reference, we
are going to call the game over event. And we know
that our game over event in the HUD Reference,
if I double click it, it's over here, it's going
to set the visibility to visible to the game over
text and the restart text. And it's going to play
our animation that we have previously created that
we also explained. And last but not least, if this
needs to loop 30 times, for example, as I said,
if the snake has 30 body parts, and this leads
to loop 30 times, but the head is colliding with
let's say the 10th element in the array. Well,
we don't need to loop anymore. And what we can
do is we can simply break out of the self.
So break self, re, self, how did I name this?
Brett, I said the bake. So it's break. There you
go. So break self. Again, let me just go over here
break self self collision test loop. And this
is pretty self explanatory. So this is going to
call this Custom Event over here, which is going
to simply break the loop and it's going to stop
looping, Compile and Save that. Now there is no
need to explain this, again, what is happening.
So if something is not clear, as I already
explained everything, you can rewind and see,
if it's not clear, something is not clear,
make sure that you ask in the comment below.
But over here when all of this happens. So
if we make a test, and none of these is true,
so this over here, it's not true. So we don't
go inside of this condition, then the loop will
complete then it will go over here in the
output. So this output now I can go back
in the main event over here. So this output
now goes from here, now what we are going to do
is I'm going to get the wall. So wall block array.
So now we are going to test if we are colliding
with the wall, meaning all of those bounds that we
have over here. So if we are colliding with these
bounds that are set over here that we saw a moment
ago, but I'm going to right click on the wall and
collapse the node and this is going to be check
head wall collision. And notice I'm only checking
with the head because it's not possible for the
body parts of the snake to collide. Now the output
over here, we do not need it, because we are not
gonna do anything else over here. So what's gonna
happen here, again, we aren't going to have a
for each loop with a break. And execution goes
over here, the array that is going to be looped
over is this one wall blocks array. And again,
we need to create another Custom Event. So
custom event, and this is going to be break wall
collusion test loop, and this one is going to go
inside of the break. There you go. So Compile and
Save that we're basically going to do the exact
same thing we did a moment ago for the for the
wall, except what we did is for the snake.
So over here, we're going to take the snake
parts array and we are going to get the element
that's at index zero meaning the head so get,
and is going to get over here see this is the
index here. If I hover over given an array,
and an index returns a temporary copy of the item,
and over here, as you can see the index is zero
meaning the head is the first element then from
here we're going to get the actor location. Now
over here, we're not going to test if the array
index is not equal to zero because we can collide
with any wall part. There is no wall part that is
an exception over here. So from the array element,
we're going to say get actor location. And
over here now we are going to test these two.
So what's gonna happen first, let me just move
these a little bit back so that they are something
like this close to each other. I'm going to test
equals equals with a tolerance over here 0.001 As
you can see, and that means we have collided with
the wall, which means over here, the loop body
goes in a sign of a branch. There you go, and this
is plugged in over here. So Compile and Save that.
So now if this is true, basically Everything
is going to happen same as what we did before.
So over here, we're going to kill the snake.
Next, we are going to get our HUD Reference.
And from there we are going to say Game
Over event. And last but not least,
we are going to break outside of the loop.
So we're going to call break wall collusion,
test loop, and output can stay over here.
Now again, the only difference between this
what we did over here and what we did over here is
that over here, we're testing if we are colliding
with the head of the snake. But over here we are
testing. If we are colliding with any of the wall
elements, as you can see wall block, were getting
that array element, its location, if the location
matches with the location of the snake head, if
that is true, kill the snake Game Over event,
so on and so forth. Everything else you already
know, we already explained, then over here, the
execution continues. So make sure that you Compile
and Save that if something is not clear, make
sure that you ask in the comment below. Moving
forward in the second sequence over here do next
or do second, excuse me, we are going to perform
a check again, if the snake is dead. So over here,
I'm going to right click collapse nodes. And this
one is going to be check that condition to and
this goes over here, double click it and simply
we are going to go in a branch which we know is
a true or false statement. So over here, we're
going to plug this in. And only if it's false,
it is going to go over here. And what I'm going
to do is I'm going to say not that like this,
and we can Compile and Save this bad boy. So the
next step is to so this goes over here like this
and moving forward. Next, we are going to go
in a sequence again. So right click over here,
sequence search for a sequence, right click on
it to collapse a node, and this one is going to
be our sequence to double click it and it goes
like this, these two go in here. So let me just
go and click here, then we are going to say do
first same as what we did before. And over here,
we're going to say do second, and Compile and
Save that. Let's go back, and this goes over
here. So again, we have a sequence. If the
snake is not that, notice that here we have
not that condition. And over here. We also have
the knots that condition but we also have the
is that condition for the snake as you can see. So
moving forward, what's gonna happen inside of this
sequence now? Well, in this sequence, we have
a couple of things in the first one that is.
So for the first one, I'm going to right click,
and I'm going to create a branch. And I'm going
to right click on the branch and collapse a
node and this one is going to be check had food
collision and you got it right, this over here is
going to check if we have collided with the foods
for our snake and it goes like this, so
Compile and Save that input goes in the
branch and the condition for the branch
is going to be from the snake bites array.
So from the snake parts array, we are going to get
the element that's at index zero meaning the head
of the snake and we are going to get the location
of it. So we're going to say get actor location.
There you go. Next, what we need to do is we
need to get a reference to the food actor.
So here is our food actor, we can only have one
food actor in the game at any given moment. So
we only have one and we are going to get the
actor location as well, for the food actor
like this. Now we are going to test these do so
equals equals and plug this in but over here,
this time the tolerance is not going to be 0.0001
instead of that the tolerance is going to be one
if I hover over returns true if x vector is equal
to vector b within a specified error tolerance. So
this one so one unit is the specified tolerance
that we well specified. So that's like you know,
one one unit or one centimeter in Unreal Engine
in Unreal Engine measurements. So if it's true,
we are going to plug in over here the execution if
it's false, we are not going to plug in so if it's
false, we're not going to do anything but output
goes only if it's true what we're doing again,
we're getting the element that's at either zero
we know that's the head of the snake, getting the
location of the head of the snake, getting the
food actor and its location do their location
match with one centimeter or one measurement unit
of Unreal Engine tolerance. If that is true, then
Go into the output, make sure that you Compile and
Save that. So this goes over here like this. So
only if it's true the next step what we are going
to do, and I'm going to take these two inches
mobilebet down so that I can move these over here.
The next step is we are going to update the game
score. So what I'm going to do is I'm going to get
my actually we are going to get the food actor,
here it is, and right click on him and collapse
the node and this one is going to be update score.
So actually is going to be update games course
excuse me for that one, because we already have a
function name or an event custom event name update
score. So update game score, it goes like this.
What's gonna happen with the food the actor,
we are going to get the score. If you remember,
the food actor has its own score, if I double
click it, so can I double click it to open it in
the foot doctor, apparently not for some whatever
reason, but here it is, we have this score,
and we set it over here we talked about that, she
can rewind those videos if you need a refresher.
So now from here, we are going to right click
and we're going to get the update score.
And this goes over here, and the score value goes
over here. And this goes over here. There you go.
So this is going to update our score again, you
can double click this function and go over here
and see what it is doing. It is taking the current
value over here the score, adding it to the score,
setting the score over here and then passing it
to the HUD Reference so that we can actually have
our score. But this only happens again, this only
happens if this is true. So if we collide with the
food actor, because if we don't collide with
the food actor, of course, we are not going to
update the score. Next, now that we have
collided with the food actor updated the score,
we are going to destroy the reference to the food.
So we're going to get the food actor and I'm going
to again collapse the node and this is going to be
this truly correct current food. Because we picked
it up, we don't need it anymore. So from here, we
are going to call these Troy actor. There you go,
this goes over here, the plugin goes over here and
this is plugged in over here. Again, we picked up
the food, there is no need for us to have that
food anymore in our game, because now we are
going to create a new food so destroy the current
one. Let's go back, this execution goes over here.
The next step for us is to spawn a new snake part
because the snake if it's this big, for example,
and it eats a new food, it go it grows bigger.
So for that we are going to get our snake parts
array, right click on it and collapse the node.
And this one is going to be spawn new snake part
spawn snake. So we're going to say spawn snake
new part like this, because we already have spawn
new snake part, apparently. So here we have our
snake parts array, what we are going to do is we
are going to get over here, but we're not going
to get that element that's at the first index
instead. From here, we're going to say last index,
and this is going to return the last index of our
snake meaning the element that's at the last place
inside of our snake. And the reason for that is
because we need to get the location, so get actor
location, we need to get the location of the last
part of our snake so that we can call over here
our custom event spawn new snake part as you can
see. So from here, this is plugged in over here.
And we can do something like this. This goes over
here, this goes over here, this goes over here.
And this goes a little bit over here, just so
that we can clearly see it. So this is going
to be plugged into the spawn location. Of course
it's not a head because we're spawning a new snake
part. And notice here the beauty of this. So as
I said we're spawning a new snake part it needs
to go at the end of the snake. So this is the
snake's head Part Part Part Part snake eats this
food we are spawning a new snake part over here,
which is the last element. So what we are doing,
we are getting the last index gets the last
valid index in this array, we are getting that
and then we're getting the location of that actor
and we are putting that as a spawn location here
in our snake bar because we know that we're
going to use the location to actually spawn
so we're using the location to actually spawn
that snake part. So Going back over here,
this execution continues here, spawn snake
bar response snake new part. Moving forward,
we already know that we have destroyed our food,
which is over here. So we need to spawn a new one.
So we're going to right click over here, we're
going to say spawn food, this is going to spawn
a new food, we can connect these right away.
But in order to follow what we did so far, with
the collapse graphs, we can simply right click on
it, then we can see spawn new food, there you go.
And this goes over here like this, and this goes
over here, like this. And we can go back and now
we can plug in the execution. But as I said, we
can directly do that on the, on the custom event,
as well. so we can directly do it. But just you
know, because we are having all of these collapse
notes. Well, we can follow it over here as well.
The last step that we need to do over here is to
speed up the snake. And for that, we're going to
get our delay and right click on it and collapse
the node and this one is going to be speed up
snake. And what's going to happen over here,
now we have our delay, I am going to go over here
and I'm going to say minus or actually plus float,
and the value of the flow that we are going to
add to our snake is going to be negative 0.01. So
we're actually going to subtract from it. And over
here, we are going to say set the delay. So this
goes over here, and this goes a little bit over
here, because we are going to get our clamp float.
There we go, we are going to clamp this value that
we get over here. And the minimum can be 0.0 75.
And the maximum is going to be 0.2. And this goes
over here and this goes over here. There you go.
So Compile and Save that this is going to actually
speed up our snake. So this is going to speed up
our snake because the delay is how much we are
waiting. And when we have a lower value, we are
waiting less, which means the snake will move
faster. So again, what we are doing is over here
for the output, we don't have to do this, we don't
have to have the output because this is the last
collapse node in this line of sequence that we are
going to execute. So taking the delay subtracting
from 0.01 value clamping that value, which is not
going to allow us to go below the minimum which is
0.0 75. And it will not allow it to go above the
maximum which is zero point to set that value over
here into the delay and there you go. But we
also need to plug in this execution over here,
so that it actually executes. So this is
our do first sequence. So we are testing
for the head collision, updating the score,
if we have the head collision with the food,
updating the score, destroying the current
food, spawning a new snake part destroying,
or actually creating a new food and then speeding
up the snake we explain everything what it is. But
in case if something is not clear, just make sure
that you ask in the comment below. Moving forward,
there are only two parts left in our game. And
they're going to happen over here do seconds. So
from this sequence, right click over here,
and we are going to create a new sequence.
And I'm going to right click on this sequence
and collapse the node and this one is going to be
check inputs. So we are going to check for the
input. If we press the button to move the snake
and then we are going to move that snake so we're
actually going to move the snake afterwards.
So let me go back over here, this goes over here.
And there you go. So inside of our check inputs,
we are going to have 01, then two, then three,
and then four of these sequences. On the fourth
sequence, we are gonna go in the output from zero
to three, we are going to check for the input. So
we are going to check for the input for when up
is presence on and so forth. Let me just go and
do my thing. So what we're going to do is right
click over here and we are going to create a gate.
And this gate is going to be controlled with the
input up. And over here. This is what we want.
So this goes over here in this gate. And let me
just double click this bad boy, this goes like
this, and this goes over here. And probably
we will need to move a little bit upwards for
other sequences to have place to you know stay
to be visible. So we're here this is our first
so when we press the up button on our keyboard so
when we press it, we're going to open the gate.
When we release it we are going to close the gate.
Now, another thing that you can do is you can go
into the project settings in the input and over
here in the action mappings you can create your
own action mappings if you want to move the
snake And the W key on other keys, whatever,
but you will have to create your own action
inputs. Because currently by using this over here,
we are only going to move the snake when we press
the up arrow key on our keyboard. If I hover over
you see events for when the up key is pressed,
or released. So this is the up arrow key on the
keyboard Anyways, what we are going to do when we
enter this sequence, which is this one over here,
so do second, we're going to check in the inputs,
and we are going to go in this in the sequence,
this sequence the sequence, this sequence is
going to check if when we enter, so we're going
to enter this gate, and I open the gate, the gate
implementation, but we don't need that anyways,
when we enter the gate, we're going to wait if we
press the up arrow key, and when we release it,
when we press it, we are going to open the gate
and execute what's over here, when we close the
gate, all the execution stops. So what's gonna
be executed over here? Well, we are going to go
inside of a branch. So when we press the up arrow
key, we're going to go in the branch. And what we
are going to test over here is the direction z.
And we are going to test if that is equal to zero.
So over here, testing data if it's equal to zero,
and from here, we just say, and so we're going to
test to Booleans. If direction z is equal to zero,
and get can change direction. So if we can change
direction, and the direction z is equal to zero,
that goes over here plugged in as the condition
if that happens, if it's true, we are going to
set the direction x to zero. And we're going
to set the direction z to one, there you go. And
last but not least, after that we are going to set
here can change direction, we are going to set it
and this goes over here like this. And I'm going
to double click this to have this line over here
so that we can plug in all of these others. So
we're going to plug them in later on, because over
here can change direction is going to be false.
But we're going to do for all of these for all of
our inputs. Because now what we are going to do is
I'm going to copy this gate, actually, I can copy
all of this here, I can copy it, and I can paste
it over here. So now this goes, execution goes
over here. But let me just again, select them and
move them over here because we do have space now.
And what I'm going to do now we have the up key.
Now we want the down key. So from here, I'm going
to right click, and I'm going to input down.
And let me just find it over here. Here it is
input down when the down key is pressed. And let
me just double click this over here and move this
execution like this. And this press goes here,
release goes here, same thing, same explanation
as what we did. And you can move this a little bit
further so that you can distinguish these lines
over here. But same explanation, same everything,
as for this one above. But this time only when
we press the down key, we're going to open the
gate when we release it, we're going to close
it. If the direction z again is equal to zero,
and we can change direction. If that is true,
both of these we can copy and paste them again.
And we can plug this in. So if it's true, the
direction x is going to be zero, the direction z
is going to be negative one because we're
moving downwards and down is the negative side
up is the positive down is the negative
right is the positive plus and over here
left is the negative. And last but not least, then
this goes over here so that we can the note that
we cannot change the direction currently. Next, we
can copy this gate, so I can paste it over here.
And this goes over here the execution flow goes
over here like this. Next, we are going to get
the input for our right key. So when we press the
right key, so over here, I can say something like
input, right. And this is the one that we want
not right alt bracket command and blah, blah,
blah, only where it says right, and this goes
over here and this goes over here. There you go.
And I can probably do something like this, so
it is a little bit more visually clear what we
are doing. So now when we have this gate, again,
we're going to go inside of a branch, the branch
goes up to here, but this time instead of getting
the direction z we are going to get the direction
x because now we are moving on the left and right
side. And if the direction x is equal to zero,
and again, we can change direction so we're going
to get it over here. So if the direction x is
equal to zero and we can change direction. If both
of these are true. And by the way, if you're a
complete beginner don't know what this end means.
It means that this over here needs to be true. And
this over here needs to be true. If for example,
direction x is not zero, but can change direction
is true, this whole thing will be false. When this
is true, if direction x is zero, and that is true,
and can change direction is true, only then this
will return true. And this over here will execute.
So basically, both of these conditions needs to
be true. So when that happens over here, we're
going to say set direction x and the direction
x, we are going to set it to be one because now
we are moving to the right side in the positive
side, and over here, set directions z is going
to be equal to zero because we're not moving on
the z axis and this goes over here. There you go.
Last but not least, we can basically copy all of
this, and we can paste it over here like this,
and execution goes over here, enter the gate,
right click. And now when we right click,
so right click again, input left. Again, it's
not left command Ctrl Shift, it's only where it
says left. So over here, pressed goes into open
released goes into clothes. If the direction x
is equal to zero, and we can change the direction,
if both of these are true, the direction x
is going to be negative one. And the direction
z is going to be equal to zero. And last but not
least, the plug goes over here so that we can set
that we cannot change direction. So make sure that
you Compile and Save that then last but not least,
which is our last sequence, the fifth one, it is
going to go into the output so that we can proceed
and you know, you can click here instead of then
four, you can say next, for example, Compile and
Save that so that we can proceed and do the last
step, which is actually moving the snake, because
this over here is going to only get us the input.
So again, I went through all of this, it
is pretty self explanatory. It's not hard,
this code over here is not hard at all.
So we're simply setting based on which
button we pressed either for the Z or for the x,
we're setting it to one or negative one. That's
all what we are doing. But if something is clear,
make sure that you ask in the comment below.
So over here, we're checking the input. And well
the next step is to actually move the snake. So
in the last step over here, first we are going
to create a for loop and create a four loop,
right click on it, collapse the node and this one
is going to be move snake and this is going to be
used to move our snake double click this bad boy.
And the input goes in the for loop. And I'm going
to save this go back over here so that I can plug
in the execution order and go back inside again,
the output, we are not going to need it. This
is the last step. So we are getting close.
So what's going to happen over here what is the
first index is zero, the last index is going to
be our snake parts array. And we're going to
get the length. So actually simply here type
Lang to actually linked with th not
HD. Now that we have the length,
I am going to subtract from it.
So I'm going to say minus integer.
There you go. And I'm going to plug this in over
here. What am I doing? If I go here, Snake parts
array and get the number of items in the array. So
we are getting the number of items, how many items
do we have, if we have 30 items, we are getting 30
items from that array, the input can go over here.
And I'm subtracting one because the last the last
index, the last element in the array is always
at the length minus one. So from zero up to the
length minus one, which is the last element over
here, when we complete the movement, we're going
to say set can change direction to true, because
if you remember a moment ago, we changed over
here, we set it to be false. So now we need to set
it back to true to be able to move again. And this
goes over here because well this is the last step.
So when you complete the loop can change direction
will be equal to true. Now what is going to happen
in the loop body. We are going to go inside of a
branch and I can move this over here so you can
more visually see this more clearly. Now what's
going to happen over here is that I am going
to get the snake parts array again. From the
snake parts array. I'm going to get the link
again. So getting the length last but not least
I'm going to say minus integer, so we're going to
subtract from it one again. And from here, we're
going to say minus integer again. But this minus
integer is going to be the index from here, or
the current index that's being iterated. So the
point here is that we loop through the whole
array and get every element that's inside of our
get every element that's inside of the snake. And
from there, we are going to move that element. And
this is how we are going to get those elements. So
we are going to get the snake parts that already
and the length of it. So length minus one, which
is the last element. So let's say we have 10
elements in the array, that means the length
will be equal to 10 minus one that is nine. Next,
we are going to subtract from nine, the current
index that's being iterated that can be 012345,
blah, blah, blah, up to when it gets
to the number nine, this will allow us
in reverse to move the snake parts. So it will
not actually move the snake parts from the head.
And then the second part and the second part
and the third part of the fourth part, instead,
it will remove the snake from the last element,
then the second to last, then the third to last,
and so on and so forth. So this is what we are
doing over here. So now what we are going to
do from here is again, I'm going to get the snake
parts array. And from here, I'm going to see get,
which is going to get the element added the
current index, which is this one over here.
So the index that we have calculated
with this that I have just explained
next over here are going to test his head.
So we are testing each of the elements that
we are getting, if it's the head that goes
over here inside of our branch condition,
because we need to know which one is the head and
which one is not the head. Now moving forward,
what we are also going to do is I'm going to copy
these two and paste them over here. Because again,
this goes over here like this, again, we are going
to get then what I'm going to do is move this,
like this over here. So again,
we are going to get the element
that's on the current index, and also from here.
So from here, again, we are going to say minus
integer. And we're going to subtract one from
this value. And again, we are going to paste this,
and we are going to get this element again.
So we're getting the two elements right
next to each other this is what we are doing
with these two. Now what is going to happen
is we have the true and we have the false. If
it's true, we have the head, we are going to
say over here add actor, world offset. This
is if it's true. So this goes over here.
If however, it's false, then we're going to say
set actor location. So over here, we're going to
say set actor, location. And here it is. This is
if it's false. And we're going to go over here.
And probably we'll need to move these to just a
little bit over here. So what is going to happen
right now? Well, the target for both of these
is going to be this one. So this goes over here
as the target and this one goes over here as the
target. So make sure that you plug these two in
correctly or otherwise it will not work. The next
step that we were what we need to do is from here,
we are going to get the actor location, there you
go. And this location, this actor location goes
over here. So we're going to plug it in over
here. And last but not least here at the top,
I'm going to right click and split the pin
structure and we are going to get the direction
x get the direction x get the direction z and we
are going to multiply these students so this can
be moved a little bit over here because x will be
multiplied with float and the value that's going
to be multiplied is 100. We can copy and paste
this over here and multiply z with 100 as well.
And now these 2x goes here
in the X and Z goes in the Z,
the location y we're not going to touch that so
location y we are not going to touch it instead,
we location y stays as is. Now let me go briefly
again what we did over here, so Compile and Save
that. So this is explained what we did we get the
last element minus one we're looping that many
times. From here when all of this completes when
the loop completes. When we loop through the whole
loop, then what we are going to do is simply set
can change direction to true so that we can change
the direction again, over here we're getting
the snake parts array, and we're subtracting
from it the index, which will allow us to
get the every element inside of the array.
From here, we are checking if the snake
parts are the element that's at this array,
this index currently, if that is the head, if
it's true, we are using actor or add actor world
offset, and we are changing the actors location
x and z by using the direction x multiplying it
with 100 and direction z multiplying that by 100.
We know the direction x or z, it's going to be
either one or minus one for both of these. So this
is going to be negative and positive 100 for the
offset of the head of the snake. Moving forward,
and over here we are plugging in we are getting
the element that's this index. So we are getting
that element that we're plugging that in over
here is the target and doing the same thing over
here for this one for set actor location as well.
Moving forward from there, what we are
going to do is we are getting the next
element in that array. So let's assume this
over here. So when we calculate these two,
let's assume this has a value of 10. Over here,
we say minus one, that means this has a value of
nine. So over here we are getting, as you can see,
we are getting the element that's add the value or
index 10. But we are setting its location
to be where the index that has a value,
nine to be that way we are moving them so that
way we are moving them. So let's assume this is
the head of the snake, we're getting that element
that's here and setting his location to be over
here. And this we're doing with every single
one of these. So this one will move the location
over here, this one will move on the location
over here. If we have more of these over here,
this one will move on this location, this one will
move on this location, just make sure that you
Compile and Save this. And now we can go back
and test it out. So if I go back into gameplay,
hit the play button, you will see now the snake
is moving and bam you see when we hit on or when
we touch one of these walls. Well as you can
see, we die. So we need to press the R button
to restart the game but it's not working. And also
if I try to play the game again, I'm moving left
and right but it's not working what is happening.
Well there is one more thing that we need to do.
Over here we need to select the BP main game and
scroll down so BP main game which is in the world
outliner over here and scroll down and go over
here where it says the input as you can see,
we need to say out to receive input not disabled
but player zero meaning that we will receive this
blueprint this actor BB main game will receive the
input if it doesn't receive the input. While you
saw a moment ago what will happen. So if I hit the
play button now if we hit one of these walls, bam,
you see we die. Game over press R to restart the
game via press the our game is restarted. And now
you see I can move the snake you see I can move it
up, left and down. And now I have picked up one of
these as you can see, picked up one of the foods.
Let's try to eat another one and bam we died.
So let's try again. So over here, over here, there
you go. Let's try it one more time. There you go.
We are eating the food pay attention to the score
it is moving to 100 now we have score at comma on
210. Again, eating and pay attention every single
time The more we eat the larger the snake and the
faster the snake is. So let's go over here and
I don't know if you're asking me What's this
in the middle this like I don't know this over
here. I don't know what that is maybe some kind of
glitch, whatever. It's not important if somebody
knows just tell me so 580 680 and now I can even
move the snake a little bit faster and better and
more clearer. If you have issues with the control
in the beginning that's because of the delay.
So you see the lower the delay is the faster
the snake is and the better control over it the
we have. So there you go. And notice now when I
die with the snake It doesn't matter if I hit
the wall or if I actually hit the snake body.
You see you saw how the snake like this appeared
in an animation. Well that animation is if we go
if we go let me just see where it was over
here. flipbook actually it's in the kill snake.
So let's go over here. Let me just find kill
snake, here it is. So these are the flip books
that we are using our animations, we explain how
you can create them. And you can go and check
them out and see how they look like. But this is
what we are doing. So over here we're adding the
flipbook on every one of those animations. So
now, you saw the effect of that. So let me just
play one more time. The last step that I want
to test out is do we actually die if the snake
collides with its own body, so let's go back over
here try to eat it, it is a little bit harder to
control the snake when we didn't want it then
when the snake is not big enough, so when it
didn't eat enough, so come on, let's try it one
more time, we need to get the snake a little bit
bigger so that we can actually come on man,
I cannot be the game I created. What is this?
Actually not beat it I'm trying
to die. But I'm trying to die with
the with colliding on the snakes by anyways,
you can simply set the delay to be a lower value
in order for that to work. So the delay can have
a lower value as well. In the beginning, that
is you see, the larger the snake the faster it is
the delay is slower and that means we can control
the snake much better. So meaning you can, as
I said, set the delay in the beginning to be
smaller value. So now we can actually test it
out. So pay attention now the snake is moving
and we can control it way better. And now bam,
you see I collided on my own tail and I died
you can restart the game by pressing R to play
the game again. And that is that thank you again
for watching one or one another one of my Unreal
Engine tutorials here on YouTube. And please, if
you liked the video, make sure that you share it,
subscribe to the channel, comment and leave a like
because that helps the algorithm helps my channel
grow because we want to spread the roots. We're
we want to spread the word so that other people
can see and benefit same as like you did. Anyways,
thank you again for watching. If you want more
Unreal Engine tutorials, I have plenty more inside
of my game development Academy link is in the
description below. Click on that link enroll you
will learn you will help support the channel and
it's very cheap, cheaper than any other website.
Anyways, I don't have anything else clever to
say except again, help the algorithm push the
channel forward then the fire here from us who's
calm. I will see you guys in the next tutorial.